well we are going to talk about internet
censorship so the main components of
communication are usually who is talking
to whom and what are they talking about
so usually the who portion is called the
users the whom portions is called the
publisher which provides some
information to the user and the what
part is the information itself so
internet censorship comprises of a range
of steps that the censor might take to
either stop the publication of
information on the publisher side or
discourage access to that information
over the links that connects the user to
the publisher or directly coerce users
not to access that information but the
key point is to stop the information
from being disseminated I'll give you a
very simple example of how censorship
takes place which Ford kind of gives us
also an idea of what are different
mechanisms available if youtube.com has
been blocked and I am a user usually the
set of steps that would take place is
that I would type youtube.com into my
browser then behind the scene my browser
will generate a query to a DNS server
okay it was youtube.com but now it's
abc.com so it will generate a DNS query
to the local DNS server asking what is
the IP address to which I should map ABC
com
now either the DNS server would already
know the IP address corresponding to
abc.com or it would ask other DNS
servers recursively on the internet and
somehow find the IP address
corresponding to abc.com once it has
that IP address it will return that IP
address to the user then the users
browser will use that IP address to
connect to abc.com which is at 1.2.3.4
and send an HTTP GET request for some
index page and if it all works
well then abc.com would respond with the
corresponding web page now as you can
see this involves interaction with
in different entities what a sensor can
do is that it can block the users
connection at this point so when the
user asks for the IP address
corresponding to abc.com the sensor
controlled DNS server could either say
that this domain does not exist or it
can say that oh the IP address
corresponding to this domain name is
4.4.4 dot four which is something which
is under the control of the sensor this
is called DNS redirection or DNS sink
holing then at the IP layer say if it
doesn't block the connection at this
layer then in the next step what a
sensor can potentially do is that it can
block users attempt to connect to
1.2.3.4 which is called IP blocking and
then there is this concept of
application layer blocking which doesn't
involve the domain name or the IP
address but rather a sophisticated
sensor might be able to look at the
content that is traveling over this
channel between the user and abc.com and
if it finds some offensive keywords
which are indicative that this
connection is carrying some information
which should be censored then based on
that keyword it will send TCP it can
potentially send TCP reset packets to
both sides or do something else - just
drop packets - just disrupt the
communication for the connection okay
different people get into trouble when
they try and go to these sites what is
it it is that something can be traced
whether if yes yeah so when we talk
about the human element of censorship
resistance this involves publishers of
information and also the users of
information and that basically goes into
the area of privacy and anonymity so
basically anonymity ensures that the the
users of a censorship resistant system
may not be traceable and what you just
mentioned it's called coercion of users
or coercion of publishers and or ideally
one of the goals of comprehensive
censorship resistant systems is to
afford that kind of privacy to users but
usually they don't do that
and that's use will usually
something that users have to take care
of themselves by combining their use of
censorship resistant systems with
anonymity so this is like tor I know
that a long time ago people would block
out things in newspapers or block out
things in images and that would be a
form of censorship so how does it work
then when people are censoring in these
levels we've just talked about and yet
the censorship resistant software out
there what's going on what will be the
next thing I think it's it's like an
arms race right because the technology
that is used to disseminate and retrieve
information is constantly evolving so
now we have social media websites like
Twitter Facebook which have loads and
loads of user-generated content so on
the one and it is very difficult for a
censor to retain that control of
information because now there's this
whole bulk of information to to go
through and then also because this
content is hosted by sites like Google
or Twitter here so they can't just block
the IP address of Twitter and block the
IP address of Google because that would
incur a lot of collateral damage the
false positives that we previously
talked about but when the sensor ups
their game then the censorship
resistance systems also take the next
step up so there's basically a
cat-and-mouse game which is in play here
what net can use it spots for
distributed computing for example
distributed password cracking getting
boards to solve captures let's get the
Google glass in there there it is I
think I'd be tempted to position it a
bit further along the line here it's not
quite as